if a person would sit down and let their
body relax totally relax okay and then
start to visualize in their mind see
themselves the way they want to see
themselves and see how you'd like to
live your life see yourself living it
that way okay now understand that that's
a picture in your mind take that picture
and describe it write it out start to
read it and read it and read it and read
it every day carry it around and keep
reading it the one point that all the
great teachers all down through history
have all agreed on they've been in
complete unanimous agreement on it we
become what we think about
now it may be fantasy at first it might
even appear to us as being a lie but if
you read it often enough you'll start to
believe it now a lot of people will
laugh at this and say that doesn't make
any sense it makes a lot of sense they
can't tell you why it doesn't I could
spend hours telling you why it does and
I could explain it in such detail that
everyone would understand it